es wird ihn nicht entgangen sein endlich
mal ein großer Schlag gegen das
organisierte Verbrechen gegen den
Endgegner des deutschen Rechtsstaats
richtig die klimakleber ja
Razzien in sieben Bundesländern wegen
Verdachts auf Gründung einer kriminellen
Vereinigung das ist juristisch sehr
umstritten aber die Nerven halt es
wirklich Wahnsinn es ist der Wahnsinn
unsere Strafverfolgungsbehörden haben
gerade insgesamt so einen Lauf ja
neulich gab es ja erst die große Razzia
gegen die italienische Mafia die
wahrscheinlich zweit gefährlichste Bande
nach der letzten Generation ja die Mafia
man schätzt
man kann nur schätzen aber man schätzt
dass sie allein in Deutschland irgendwas
zwischen 50 und 100 Milliarden angelegt
haben in Pizzerien natürlich Eisdielen
aber auch in Autowaschanlagen
die Beamten sind auch hier noch vor Ort
haben allerdings auch schon einiges
sichergestellt zum Beispiel mehrere Kilo
Drogen und das ist ein guter Hinweis
darauf dass es sich hier eben nicht nur
um ein simples pflegefahrzeugpflege
Unternehmen handelt ja ja Drogen sind
oft so Indizien meine Damen und Herren
ne ja wenn sie nach der premiumwäsche
mit Heißwachs Kokain im Kofferraum
finden
gerne der Polizei melden die freut sich
die Mafia fühlt sich offensichtlich
pudelwohl bei uns in Deutschland weil
wir ein Geldwäsche Paradies sind ja
deswegen hat uns die EU ja schon zwei
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren aufgepumpt
auf der anderen Seite ich meine auch
Mafia Geld ist natürlich Geld die
verhalten sich unauffällig zahlen
Steuern und konsequenter Weise ist es
hier bei uns nicht mal strafbar Mafia
Mitglied zu sein letztlich ist das ja
auch nur eine Art Firma die kalabrische
Mafia machte im Jahr 2013 übrigens einen
Umsatz von etwa 53 Milliarden Euro das
ist mehr als McDonald's und die Deutsche
Bank zusammen durch ihre Kassen ziehen
ich frage mich gerade wer hat mehr
Menschenleben auf dem Gewissen
die Mafia oder McDonald's
schwierig und wie schön dass ich unsere
Innenministerin Nancy Faeser so feiert
für die Razzia gegen die Mafia letztlich
ging das alles nur mit internationalen
Haftbefehl nicht mit deutschen Christian
Lindner wiederum hat am Tag der
Verhaftung zu einem Pressetermin beim
Zoll geladen da durften sich mehrere
Ninja Turtles als Komparsen hinter ihm
den Arsch Abschwitzen damit der Minister
cooler aussieht aber warum trägt der Typ
links ein bierdosenhelm
rätselhaft rätselhaft im Kampf gegen
Geldwäsche selbst Lindner vor allem auf
eine Behörde namens fiju sitzt hier in
Köln während Chef ist im Dezember
zurückgetreten nachdem bei ihm kein Witz
290.000 Geldwäsche verdachtsmeldung
unbearbeitet auf dem flurlagen
einige schon Jahre alt aber das wird
jetzt alles besser Freunde denn Lindner
Gründe zwei weitere Behörden die
Bundesoberbehörde zu Bekämpfung der
Finanzkriminalität und das organisierte
kriminalitätsbekämpfungszentrum beim
Zoll wow
da knallen bei den zöllernen doch
bestimmt die Korken oder am Ende wird
die weltliche Bekämpfung dadurch
komplizierter behäbiger strukturell
unübersichtlicher und wir haben wirklich
keinen Benefit dadurch
was für ein undankbarer Mann oder
tatsächlich würden wohl nur drei Sachen
wirklich helfen gegen Geldwäsche mehr
fahrender vor Ort die Beweislastumkehr
also wenn ich nicht erklären kann wo das
Geld für meinen Ferrari herkommt wird er
beschlagnahmt und ganz wichtig endlich
eine bargeldobergrenze 18 von 27
EU-Staaten haben längst eine
Griechenland liegt die bei 500 Euro
Spanien 1000 €. brauchen wir nicht sagt
unser Finanzminister in der Rap-Szene
bekannt als Kapital Bar wie brav wegen
bargeld ist egal ist egal hier Lindner
Staatssekretär wir glauben dass es in
der Tat so wie es heute geregelt ist
nämlich dass die Banken verpflichtet
sind bei Transaktionen
zu hinterfragen was ist der Grund und
gegebenenfalls eine verdachtsmeldung
abzugeben dass das richtig ist ab
welchem Wert einer Bar Abhebung eine
Bank einen Geldwäsche Verdacht melden
muss
dafür gibt es in Deutschland keine
grundgesetzliche Regelung
na super
Banken und Notare also Institutionen die
letztlich auch an Geldwäsche verdienen
sollen die doch bitte melden genial
wirklich ein italienischer
Schrotthändler hat übrigens vor kurzem
insgesamt über 70 Millionen gewaschene
Euro in bar problemlos von bayerischen
Banken abheben können aber wir brauchen
keine Obergrenze wozu was ist das
eigentlich für ein komischer Fetisch mit
uns Deutschen und dem Bargeld das ist ja
fast schon krank im Grunde Knete sexuell
wirklich
gut auf der anderen Seite Deutschland
ganz ohne Bargeld was machen dann die
besoffenen Frauen beim
Junggesellenabschied was sollen die den
Stripper in die Hose stecken ohne
Geldscheine
2 0 0
von Bank Überfällen mal ganz zu
schweigen Freunde
das ist ein Überfall überweist du mir
sofort 50.000 € und zwar an meine
Paypal-Adresse Thomas Punkt online.de
[Musik]
und jetzt ganz langsam das Geld zurück
überweisen
Polizei duisburg@gmx.de
das geht auch das geht auch aber es ist
wirklich bezeichnend über diese Mafia
Razzien wurde in deutschen Medien gerade
mal einen Tag lang berichtet und dann
ging es auch schon wieder keine Ahnung
um Til Schweiger wahrscheinlich ne ja
ich habe mich dann neulich erst mit
einem Experten fürs organisierte
Verbrechen drüber unterhalten
Hauptkommissar Ulrich von Heesen Herr
Kommissar was ich mich ja Frage warum
interessiert sich bei uns kaum einer für
die Mafia ein Wort Antipasti meine eine
Gehirnhälfte sagt Drogenhandel
Waffengeschäfte und die andere keine
alles sein aber dieser Parmaschinken
ein Gedicht
dein Schinken mal
außerdem ist ja auch eine Art Kompliment
das ist ein großer internationaler
Konzern wie die Mafia sein Geld
ausgerechnet bei uns weg weil sie wissen
wir Deutschen sind ein reinliches Volk
der bayerische Innenminister fühlt sich
geschmeichelt wir wissen schon seit
längerem dass Bayern auch gerne genutzt
wird als sogenannte Ruheraum von Mafiosi
ähm dort wo sie erst mal Untertauchen
wollen wenn sie aus dem Blickfeld
italienische Behörden verschwinden
wollen
kriminelle auch mal durchschnaufen
dürfen wir machen in Italien Urlaub und
Regens Geld bei uns in Bayern ja aber
warum müssen deutsche Politiker bei der
Mafia zum Jagen getragen werden aber
nach jeder hat es ja in der Shisha Bar
gibt es fünf Pressekonferenzen und die
Bild fordert härtere anti-clan-gesetze
also bitte was ist das denn für ein
Scheiß Vergleich Mafia und Remo Clan
schick mal den Pfeiffer rein
so siehst du selber ne schon vom Style
her Welten
war beides übel Gangster Geldwäsche das
ganze Programm aber die einen sind uns
halt kulturell etwas Fremder und die
anderen machen ein paar Maschinen
ich weiß nicht ob man das jetzt wirklich
so rein kulinarisch ja natürlich
überhaupt nicht sobald die Remos auch
meine anständige Carbonara hin
kriegen deshalb sind die beiden denn
hier
die haben wir jemals mit ihren
Sportwagen und Millionen von Cash im
Kofferraum erwischt mit anderen Worten
Jungs ihr könnt euch verpissen wir haben
nichts gegen euch in der Hand
okay und wer von denen ist
jetzt nach ihrer Expertise die
gefährlichste kriminelle Vereinigung sag
mal weder noch diesmal Zeitung welke
Razzien bei der letzten Generation die
toppt keiner
der malte soll reinkommen
jetzt guck ihn dir an mit jeder
faserkriminell weißt du was diese irre
neuerdings machen wollte dann kommst du
nie drauf einige Menschen klebten sich
an gemieteten Leihwagen fest einer von
ihnen auf dem Dach eines Autos hier
sehen wir die Bilder da krieg ich schon
Hals Menschen gefährden gut und schön
aber Autos da hört der Spaß auf
weißt du was das mit dem Lack macht der
klebt sich gerade fest was
den Bengel haue ich jetzt rechts und
links Ulrich von lesen
[Applaus]
hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf Gefällt
mir drückt und den Kanal abonniert zeige
ich euch meinen lautesten frei für das
menschliche Gehör ist der zwar nicht
wahrzunehmen aber ich würde eure Hunde
kurz rausbringen okay fertig